this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host flying solo today here
on the ramsey show
we're here to help you with your life
and your money open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five
five two two five
before i jump in with the callers i
wanna put a call out the third hour
we're gonna spend the entire hour
talking about
one of the scummiest
most horrible industries in america
today
they rip people off they mistreat their
customers
like no other
timeshares
there's 60 people in the lobby watching
my show right now and when i said that
all of them nodded
because we all know and yet
you still go to their presentation
to get a free night at the beach that's
like going into the tiger cage after the
tiger hasn't eaten
for three weeks because there's nothing
greedier than a timeshare salesman
you go into the tiger cage and you have
to pet the tiger for two hours
and not get eaten in order to get a free
pass at the zoo
here's an idea avoid the zoo avoid the
tiger
neither one of these are going to be
good for you if this is the only way you
can get to go to the zoo
or just pay the bill to go to the zoo
that's called buying a freaking hotel
room
instead of getting yourself ripped off
after you had a six-hour presentation
where they would not let you out of the
tiger cage until you got screwed
see now i'm about to do the whole show
this segment and i'm not supposed to do
that
anyway if you've been ripped off by
timeshares you have an inside
information on timeshares which is like
everybody in america apparently
it's a multi-billion dollar business and
they have officially pissed me off now
they've officially pissed me off and so
uh
we're gonna go to war mikey hope you're
ready bubba
that's the president of diamond his
name's mikey
his actual name's mike i call him mikey
we've been having a little discussion on
twitter about
what a freaking crook is and so
these guys have got to stop this and you
people have to put them out of business
by quit working with them so we're going
to do a little
discussion about the timeshare business
until they go to their knees
because i'm going to turn 22 million of
you people loose on them
because they have been screwing people
long enough
and getting away with it because of
their financial muscle and they try to
squash anybody and they've been coming
at me
and that was a dead gun mistake was a
dead gun mistake
bought and paid for crap so here we go
boys and girls if you have a thing call
in and the phone number is triple eight
eight two five 825-5225 or email us at
daveonair ramseysolutions.com and you
can be part of this third hour
and we're going to have a party a
timeshare
screw you party that's what we're having
it's time for them to quit screwing you
people and we're going to bring it up
and talk about it in detail it is
unbelievable how scummy this business is
and how nasty bad the executives in
these companies are their personal lives
oh my god filth trash and nastiness you
ought to be ashamed of yourselves
the way you people behave and it's no
wonder because it shows up in your
product
that you have no character that's how it
works
so game on boys here we go open phones
at triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple a eight
two five
five two two five bud's gonna start us
off this hour in boston
hey bud how are you ah i'm better than i
deserve i hope
um dave i'm really hoping that you can
help me out with a with a situation that
is actually making me physically ill
oh my goodness um
i want to preface this by saying that i
absolutely adore my family
and i'm trying to do my best by my dad
but my brother and i get along best when
there's a state line between us
um my wife and i have a small lake house
that's been in our family since the
1960s
we've been renting it out for the last
several years um
but it doesn't generate enough income to
offset the mortgage and expenses
but it's been better than just having it
sit there unused how did it and
how did it end up that you own it if
it's been in the family
um my grandparents bought it in 1962
when the first grandchild was born
my parents bought it from them when my
grandfather passed away
my parents were going to put it out on
the open market and i was trying to keep
it in the family
so my wife and i bought it from them
okay um
we've been talking over the last couple
of years about selling it
and unfortunately circumstances changed
a little bit last year in that my father
who
built the cabin that's on the property
passed away last august
and i'm i'm now finding myself under
increasing pressure from my mother and
my brother to sell it to him
for substantially less than market value
and they want me to allow him to lease
to own it both of which to my detriment
due to capital gains
and not being able to get out of the
mortgage my mom is
struggling with letting it go even
though it hasn't belonged to her
directly since 2005
and she doesn't use it i need to get out
of the mortgage because i promised my
dad i would take care of her
and not owing that debt i can assist my
mom financially for the remainder of her
life
kovit took away her small job she's
living on social security
how dad's illness cracked and
my brother is a spendthrift he has a he
lives in a mobile home
he has a fifth wheel camper that he owes
on and he does not need a lake house
okay no and he is also retired
so what's making you physically ill is
is that these people who have absolutely
no rights to this property whatsoever
are trying to dictate to you what you do
with this property
and everything that they dictate to you
is against good wisdom for them
or for you because we're your brother to
buy this he can't afford it it would not
be a blessing to him
right and if he leases it from you and
he doesn't pay the lease payments now we
know we've got a future problem
duh right so really you already know
what you have to do
but it's just it's just the broken it's
just it's just
it's just that everybody's going to be
pissed off when you do it
yes and that's it no matter what i do i
lose because i don't want to alienate my
mother
for the last few years of her life um if
i don't put it on the open market and
get fair market value for it my wife
will be unhappy with me
and this doesn't matter no no no no no
okay
the the first thing we got to do is the
principle is what is the
best thing to do with this property
for your brother what is the best thing
to do with this property for your mother
what is the best thing to do with this
property for your wife what is the best
thing to do with this property for you
the answer is the same to all of those
questions
whether they get it or not i'm not
trying to please your wife i'm not
trying to please your mother
i'm trying to say on the principle on
principle
i want to do the right thing because the
best thing for your mom is for you to
get in financial condition so you can
help her
the best thing for your brother is for
him to not to continue to over obligate
himself
the best thing for you is to get out of
this thing dude you got to sell this
now is somebody going to be pissed off
probably i don't think we're going to
stop that from happening
but that's not up to you that's up to
them you don't need to be nasty or mean
you just say gosh i'm so sorry honey if
i sold you this thing you wouldn't be
able to pay the payments and it would
not be a blessing to you i know it
breaks your heart when it leaves it
breaks my heart when it leaves
mama i'm so sorry i can't take your uh
your other son who's
an enabler and as codependent as he can
be and take care of him
i can't do it and you know this is
what's best for everyone involved
i'm going to be the grown-up in the room
[Music]
and then if you guys want to have a
little temper fit in the corner you
don't have to
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just thirty dollars a month get
unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month
by switching to pure top just go to
feartalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
thank you for joining us america open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five
well we just came back from dallas our
entree leadership summit event
was off the chain george w bush
was a stand-up comic he was absolutely
so fun
so smart so compassionate and so
i mean funny funny he doesn't he's
painting now if you didn't know and
we're talking when he came off and i
told him i said mr president that
painting stuff doesn't work out i think
you can do the stand-up comedy
that was funny and so he kept the
audience in
in stitches he was uh he's a lot of fun
it was a lot of
it's a great event with some world-class
speakers and teachers on
business the entree leadership summit is
for small business owners and leaders
and you come and learn how to lead your
business run your business better it was
incredible i'm exhausted it was uh three
16 hour days back to back to back to
back to back everything in the world we
were running a gun and i did sessions on
two two days and a small one to close
the
small talk to close the event out and it
was just
it was so emotionally draining because
it was so good
you know when you're laughing really
hard you're crying occasionally and
you're
jacked up and pumped up it just takes it
out of you so
hey we're doing it again we're going to
be in orlando next year
may 22nd through the 25th we've now
launched entree summit
for sale we put it on sale when we were
there in dallas last week
and it is not quite sold out yet
we almost sold it out while we were in
dallas but uh there'll be about 3000 of
us in orlando
um may 22nd through the 25th of 2022
uh pat lencioni will be back with us
speaking dr henry cloud
jade simmons who's a classic concert
pianist
and wonderful speaker uh my friend will
garrida
or gadara gedera i always say his name
wrong he's my friend but i do say his
name wrong
he uh started and ran for years the
number one restaurant in the world
very interesting story jay leno will be
with us
uh jamie kern lima who started it
cosmetics
and uh one of the youngest female
billionaires sold it
uh and uh cashed out dr john dolone will
be speaking christy wright will be
speaking ken coleman will be speaking
if you're a business owner or a senior
leader and you want to be in the room
you'll learn more and get connected to
more
entree leaders than than you can
possibly imagine the
energy in the room was incredible it
will be incredible it was the first time
most of these folks have been in a group
of people
again and so i they were all acting like
they were teenagers who snuck out the
window at night
and like the adults were going to come
in and stop us from doing it or
something it was uh it was so
fun we had a blast so if you're
interested in the few tickets that are
remaining
uh just text summit 244
222 summit to 44222
this will be an off the chain event
our question today comes from blinds.com
a wonderful company i'm so proud to
endorse and have for many years
find out for yourself why they're they
are the number one
online retailer of quest custom window
coverings
and it's not just because dave ramsey
endorses them it's because they do a
great job you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every time you can save more
always use the promo code it's magic
ramsey today's questions from tracy in
alabama i have a rental property for
which i'm currently holding
a mortgage i've been debating on
refinancing you're not holding a
mortgage you owe a mortgage okay
i've been debating on refinancing so i
can get rid of pmi that's good
i've read about a cash out refinance and
it seems there are some benefits that go
along with that
is that a good idea well tracy this is
the dave ramsey show where we talk about
getting
out of debt not into more debt
because that is the shortest path
between where you are and wealth
cash out means you're going to borrow
more than you currently owe
you're going the wrong direction miss
tracy and so uh
no uh you you need to refinance it and
get rid of the pmi
or maybe you need to sell it
if you need some cash maybe you're too
broke to be a landlord
that's a possibility too real estate is
only a blessing
when it makes money well i rent it for
750 of my payment is 650 you are losing
money darling
i know it sounds like 100 profit but
it's not in the real world when you
count vacancy and credit loss meaning
they don't pay when they're supposed to
oh and by the way that 3500 heat and
error went out and you make 1200 a year
it takes you three years to recoup
that you're not making money on a
hundred dollar cash flow
you're losing money this is a liability
it is not an asset
your real estate is not a blessing it's
a curse sell it
if that's you if you've got a really
nice big fat cash flow then get the
stinking thing paid off and quit asking
me about borrowing more on it and going
further in debt that's going the wrong
direction kiddo
don't do that sarah's with us in boston
hi sarah welcome to the ramsey show
what's up
hi dave thanks for having me it's a
pleasure to be on the show today
i'm honored to speak with you ma'am how
can i help
yeah so a little bit about myself i'm 27
years old
i do have a degree i did have the luxury
of my parents paying for that degree
and i do have i don't have any debt
so definitely a blessing yes i also
i also have about sixty thousand dollars
saved
um in my savings account good for you um
thank you and i have a very good job a
very stable job so
um my question for you is i have
actually not invested any of my money so
it's just kind of sitting in my bank
account
and that's including like anything for
retirement
so pretty much no investment whatsoever
um so my question for you i guess is
so how do you suggest i start investing
my money
would it be with a portion of what i've
already saved within that 60 000
range or do you think i should start
investing 15
of all future um i guess paychecks
because i know from your baby steps
uh 15 is what you recommend yes ma'am
what do you mean
so i make about a hundred thousand
dollars a year good for you well done
what do you do for a living
um i work in software sales good so oh
you got a great future and a great
career
yeah you're rocking it kiddo excellent
okay so what i am going to do is just go
back to those baby steps
of that 60 000 we need to set aside
three to six months of expenses
in a separate account for your emergency
fund
i'm gonna pick a number and just call
that 20 grand just for discussion
purposes you can decide what it is later
okay
okay but that's over there just for when
it rains and kiddo it will rain someday
okay oh i know well yeah so we're going
to set that aside say pandemic yeah it
can happen i mean things can happen so
we're going to set aside an emergency
fund now i got 40 000 and then we answer
your question with that okay
we move on to baby step four which is
fifteen percent of your income going
into retirement which is fifteen
thousand dollars a year and you're
making a hundred grand at 27.
if you only do that the rest of your
life and never get a raise which would
make you a loser
if you never get a raise in your whole
life you'll be a loser would you agree
with that
i agree okay so yeah so if you only
invest 15
000 a year in good growth stock mutual
funds in your 401k with a match or
without imagine a roth ira
or roth 401k you will have tens of
millions of dollars
when you get to 65. yeah so you're so
so you're set if you just play through
and don't screw this up and marry some
guy doesn't want to work or something
you know that kind of stuff
right so you got you got this going on
i'm so proud of you you're doing so good
now once we said that then that leaves
us 40 grand do we need that to become
wealthy no we just established that we
don't and so i'm gonna use that as your
down payment on your first home
even if you're not ready to buy a home
right now we'll just keep piling it on
there
above the 15 and we call that baby step
3b
where we're saving for a house which
you've already done it so
whenever you get ready to buy a house
you'll have 40 or however much more you
add to that not counting the fact that
you're putting 15 000 aside
because you're very frugal you make a
lot of money but you're very frugal and
careful with your money you've done a
great job you are your parents child
they did a great job saving money so you
don't have debt
yes exactly that was my that was my next
question to uh
to see if it would be smart to um to put
the rest of that money into real estate
now i think it'd be wonderful for your
first property that you live in
and a 15-year fixed rate on the mortgage
where the payment's no more
than a fourth of your take-home pay and
there's no hurry
you could do that next year you can do
that in two years
you're 27. you've got time
you can do this don't panic everybody
gets house fever
and that house fever causes your brain
to quit working
and then you buy something you shouldn't
buy and you pay what you shouldn't pay
and then you call me up later and go i
can't believe i did that well just don't
get house fever if you get a house
figure take a long cold shower it'll
wash it off
just calm down
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help
you get there visit nationalguard.com
to find out more
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt
free stage laura is with us hey laura
how are you
i'm good how are you dave better than i
deserve welcome where do you live
i am from wyandotte michigan all right
and that is near detroit yep
perfect cool well good to have you thank
you it's great to be here how much debt
have you paid off
i paid off one hundred and fifteen
thousand four hundred dollars
way to go and how long did this take you
33 months
wow and your range of income during that
time i started at 72
000 and last year i made 86 000. cool
what do you do for a living
i am a physical therapist ah pt pt
you're doing good for a pt out of the
gate because you must have just started
i did just start a few
about three years ago so i'm guessing
this is pt school it is it's all student
loans every bit student loans and you
knocked off 30 grand a year for three
years over 30 grand
almost 40. wow good for you i mean
you've been living on nothing
yup absolutely you can ask any family or
friends
i just showed up yep i showed up that's
it all you've done is work
yep pretty much yeah was it worth it
absolutely how you feel now that you're
free it is it truly is a freedom i think
i didn't expect it
that as soon as i paid off my debt i
thought to myself you know
it wasn't that bad and then i thought
what are you talking about this took 33
months of basically just
doing everything i had to do just to pay
it off yeah wow
so it's been awesome you've been hitting
it i mean you've been hitting it three
to four thousand dollars a month
is it steady like that or did you have
some big chunks or something anything
happen
um it was pretty steady but there was a
time um in my story of when i paid off a
good
about eight grand from my emergency fund
okay so that was pretty helpful but
apart from that
it's just grinding how long you've been
out of school i've been out of school
since december of 2017.
so about three years three so you
started almost immediately yep i started
in march of 2018.
okay what what prompted you to do this
because most of your
fellow graduates are still languishing
deeply in debt
right absolutely they say that their
student loans are like i hope biden
helps me
yeah instead of me helping me absolutely
i have conversations like that all the
time but
um in march of 2018 was when i got my
first job and i knew that i wanted to
pay off my debt so i
was just kind of throwing money at it
but i didn't really have a set plan and
that year december i also got another
job in a hospital
just working as a physical therapist so
i was still you know just throwing money
at it throwing money at it but didn't
really have a
set plan and then in june of 2019 my mom
had said you know what i really think
you need to listen to dave ramsey he
has a lot of what you have to say or i
love your mom yeah she's
she's great she's here but um so she had
just really encouraged me you know you
need to listen to him you need to listen
to him he's got some good principles so
i said okay i will i googled you i
listened to a podcast then another
podcast and then another podcast i
bought the total money makeover audio
book and i listened to that
and now you have an addiction now it's
really bad i talk all the time like who
wants to talk about budgets
so i had an every dollar budget app that
i started using and then i finally had
said okay how long will this actually
take me
and i had a set timeline so then it was
a matter of okay it was supposed to be
march of 20
excuse me 21 and so i was aiming towards
that aiming towards that and then
um in january of 2020 i had said that
was
when i gave the rest of my money from my
emergency fund over to my loans and
finally had the courage to bring it down
to a thousand dollars and then covet hit
in march but
immediately after you gave away your
emergency fund the world's biggest
emergency
yep and how did covet affect you um so
it actually it was
pretty tough i would say the first few
months for sure because i'm from
michigan so we got hit pretty hard
so i normally am in a clinic but we had
kind of
lessened how much we would see patients
so they pulled me into the hospital
because i had that other job so i was
able to still work but i did see some
things that were not
that pleasant i didn't get to work in
the icu or anything but i was still in
the hospital seeing patients and
it was a very trying time absolutely but
i fortunately kept my job
and then i think it was maybe like may
of 2020 and then i started delivering
groceries because i couldn't pick up an
extra shift
at the hospital and then then it went
back to my full-time job at the clinic
and then i think maybe june or july i
was able to start picking up shifts
again at the hospital so i
could work full-time and then work on
the weekends and by june i was like okay
how can i
yeah how can i pay off my debt as
quickly as possible and then i started
calculating recalculating
because i was just obsessed with it and
then i realized that i could pay it off
by the end of 2020 and i said well
nobody's doing anything anyway i'm
literally missing out on nothing so
it actually gave me this motivation and
this drive because it was something that
kept me going kept me moving and and
then on the
three years to the date that i graduated
pt school i paid my
last loan off wow or the last little bit
so where to go thank you so proud of you
thank you it's been i know your mom's
proud of you your dad's proud of you
they're with you right they came to
cheer you on yeah
so you had good cheerleaders inside the
family yeah absolutely so
um and they're here too so my mom rose
angela my stepdad scott
we just made a friend isabel who
actually just graduated college debt
free last friday oh wrong we're giving
her a little kudos too but
um the other big supporter was my now
fiance
his name is ethan and he actually
proposed to me the same month that i
paid off my loans wow good december
oh that marks that month forever it was
wow huge
that's amazing so proud of you thank you
thank you well done okay you're so
chipper and so happy and you were
in the medical field through covid yeah
you got out of debt through covid
yes um what's the secret to getting out
of debt
i would say that it's worth it and it's
your student loans don't have to be your
ball and chain
i try to talk to people about it all the
time i say okay don't let me get on my
soap box because then i
just talk all these things dave ramsey
but it really it is worth it and you
just got to find a goal
and you got to set it you got to know a
timeline so then that way you know what
to work towards and then
just race yourself to the finish line
yeah if you can put a date down and
actually have calculated it and it is
logical
there's something about just marking it
off then that keeps you going
absolutely yeah that that's versus uh
someday i'd like to
no you'll never no you got it you got to
put a date certain on stuff
yeah absolutely yeah very good yeah very
very good
thank you so good cheerleaders and
you're cheering a bunch of other people
on because i can't shut you up
yeah i know it's it's bad i'll talk to
ethan all the time hey so let's talk
about our budget
what about this what about this so it's
my new favorite
thing to talk about i love it very very
cool what does ethan do for a living
ethan is a naval officer oh wow okay
i'll tell him thanks for his service and
uh yeah you guys are gonna have a
wonderful income with those two combined
that's gonna be and no debt
wow wow wow good good future for you
yeah
excellent job what was the hardest part
of this for you
um i would say before kovid it was more
so about the not being able to spend the
money
going and going to events or people call
me cheap pretty often or i just call
myself cheap and
so wanting to be able to do more things
or spend more money but i would actually
say during covet it was
pretty helpful just because of the chaos
of everything and everything else was
uncertain but because i had this one
goal it was actually
my driver so something that was
something i knew i wanted to do but was
still pretty hard to do
then became my this is what i can focus
on
directly because medically i mean
there's a level of fear around all of
that and
in march of last year and
nobody knew what they were doing uh
everybody you know everybody's running
around talking like they knew what they
were doing but we figured out why they
why they call it practicing medicine we
watched that last year they're
practicing
and um but it's uh uh
and so for those of you in the actual
industry on the front lines it could it
could be terrifying
yeah but you've got a reason then to
step forward
versus if you didn't have a reason going
in there in the middle of that
man that would be hard because to be
motivated to put you know step up and be
front line
wow that's tough but that gave you gave
you a place to do it
and you know the net result is you're
not really at risk
right the net result is that you were
okay and that a lot of our fears were
um overblown uh it's a very serious
situation but still there's a lot of
drama around it
and uh so well done thank you very very
very well done thank you
good for you how old are you i'm going
to be 29 on saturday
hey not even 30 and you got all of this
done
well congratulations thank you well i've
got a copy of the legacy journey which
is the latest book i did
on wealth and that's where you're going
okay and then we've also got a copy of
the total money makeover for you to give
away
absolutely i've already got people in
mind i'm going to give it to so perfect
very perfect
all right laura from the detroit
michigan area 115 000 paid off in 33
months making 72-86
she did it during the pandemic shut up
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one i'm debt
[Music]
[Applause]
free
that's fun this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america this is
the dave ramsey oh it's the ramsay show
with dave ramsey today
old habits are hard to break the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five silver silver's with
us in los
angeles hi silver how are you i'm
blessed beyond measure hardware
better than i deserve what's up
so i have a lot of numbers to throw at
you but first things first
we um
a little bit muffled can you speak
directly into your phone please
oh so sorry hold on
is that any better yes ma'am thank you
okay so um we are
in a funky house situation and
we were gifted half of a house
we are purchasing the other half and it
was in a trust
so with the purchase um we have to owe
the party the other half obviously
when we first started we and just zillow
estimated the house was going to go for
500 000.
uh we did a gift of equity so we would
pay
her 250 and we did the loan for 260
because we do have a little bit of debt
we needed good faith money
so we didn't want to have to pay closing
costs so we just wrapped that into
our original escrow numbers okay i'm
sorry i'm not you got to stop a second i
i i got confused i apologize
you have a home that you live in that
you're selling
um we are purchasing the other half we
currently live there and we want to buy
the
entire house now okay so you own half
and you th
who owns the other half um
a family member okay and you're buying
them out
yes is what you're doing okay and you
need 250 000
to do that yes okay
and um so now now i'm caught up i
apologize i got lost there and so
you need 250 000 and what happened
uh so the appraisal came back because we
did all this
on a destination the appraisal came back
for less so now we need to
buy her out for 233
we're still going to wrap in our closing
costs which is right around ten thousand
so we were going to take the loan out
for 243.
okay we were approved for 260
well we were given the option that we
could still take out that 260.
so that's a 6 uh thousand dollar
difference
should we take out that um for the full
260
and use that money to pay off debt and
just kind of
wrap it into our mortgage no or should
we just minimize to the 240.
243. the very minimum you can take
okay how much of the debt do you have
um we have 38 000 in debt but
we have to have good faith money in the
account while we're purchasing
the house so 10 000 of that once the
house is finished is going to go
straight towards the debt
how much is in your account for good
faith money
a little over ten thousand but we also
have um like that's just in our savings
account we have our
uh emergency fund and then um we're just
kind of slowly paying because we can't
pay anything off until the house is
purchased
yeah you already have the house
purchased you just have to buy this
person out now do you have a mortgage on
it currently
no the house has been taken so it's
worth it it's worth a half a million
dollars and you're putting a quarter of
a million into it roughly right
yes okay i'm catching up all right but
you have enough in your savings once
this smoke all clears and the mortgage
is closed
to pay off all of your debt uh
most of our debt how much is in your
emergency fund
um we have well not counting the good
faith money so technically all together
we have twelve thousand in our emergency
fund
so to ten thousand and two thousand
because you mentioned ten thousand
earlier
yes ten thousand and two thousand okay
all right and so what we teach
is the baby steps and baby step one is a
thousand dollars anything beyond that
you would use to begin baby step two
once you get this closing done and you
don't have to have the good faith money
laying there
and um you do the baby step two
which is take everything out except the
ten thousand or except one thousand so
eleven thousand is going to go towards
the 38
uh thousand what's the 38 000 in debt
what kind of debt uh
two cars and what's your household
income
um a little over a hundred and ten
thousand okay
you got an awful lot tied up in cars
don't you
yes we realized that after i found you a
little late
okay all right but if we take 11 off of
38
that puts us at 27 and with your income
you should plow through that 27 within a
year and a half okay
and then you build your emergency fund
which is baby step three
and you move on towards building wealth
which is four five and six and so on
and so that that's what our system would
lead you to do and our system is first
going to lead you out of debt
so that you have control of your most
powerful wealth building tool which is
your income
to build wealth and so
you know we got to get rid of those car
debt and get your emergency fund in
place to lay a foundation
as soon as you get this cleared up on
the house but no you don't borrow your
way out of doubt on the mortgage
you don't finance your cars on a home
mortgage which is really what you're
asking me in essence
no i would not do that elizabeth is in
knoxville hi elizabeth welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave oh my gosh i love you so much
oh thank you you too how can we help
okay so um i am
currently working as a dietitian in a
hospital
and i've only been here for eight or
nine months
um there was a another position that
came
open very close to me about 20 minutes
down the road
and that is a significant
difference it's about fifteen thousand
dollars
more if i i applied for the job
i wasn't necessarily sure i would get it
but
they did offer it to me and it was about
a fifteen thousand dollar
rate and you make how much
okay and this would take you up to
ninety from 75 if i heard you right
yes okay how old are you
okay you're single yeah
why would you not take the better paying
job
that's what i was thinking
okay so if well something gave you pause
something made you hesitate what was it
because i didn't know
or you were just too lazy to go to work
or something you know that'd be bad
but you're getting a substantial raise
over a thousand dollars a month
exactly okay yeah um
now i do now i'm i'm a little further
away from knoxville i'm actually
uh more like harrogate tazewell area if
you know where that's at
i sure do so the position yeah so the
position
is um in kentucky so i would have to pay
tennessee and kentucky license and i
haven't figured out if that would
actually be worth the difference
um right and how far are you from the
kentucky line
20 minutes i lived right right in here
again
okay you're right right there okay wow
yeah
huh well i guess you need to find that
piece of information out
because if it's an extra ten thousand
dollars this is not nearly as appealing
with the extra commute
you're going to eat up the other five
exactly yeah
so i mean no it cost you ten thousand
dollars more in licensing then we're not
doing that i don't know what those
licenses cost to you
oh just my uh kentucky license no i
meant taxes dave
okay uh does kentucky i guess kentucky
has an income tax
they do tennessee does not okay well
it's not a hundred percent
it's probably five percent i don't know
what it is but it's not
usually state income taxes most of them
like that are three or four or five
percent
so find out what it is and net it out
and so really what you're gonna net is
not fifteen thousand you're gonna net 15
000 minus federal taxes minus your
kentucky income tax minus whatever extra
transportation costs you have by
commuting a little bit longer
so you're probably more like a ten
thousand dollar net
if that's what it sounds like to me if
you want to work
there in that setting it's going to be
another thousand dollars a month net
still so probably i'm looking at it but
it's just up to you
don't make the decision 100 on money
though it's quality of life do you want
to make that drive
is that a place you want to work is
there a quality of people you want to
work with is that a particular hospital
going to be a good
fit for you all of that they didn't
double your income they offered you 15
000.
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
theramsieshow.com
thanks for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status
symbol of choice i'm dave ramsey your
host
i'm flying solo today thank you for
joining us here on the ramsay show
good to have you guys in the third hour
the next hour
we will be dealing with one of the
scummiest industries in america today
timeshares uh
gross filth
trash and nastiness horrible
reputation everyone starts shaking their
head and laughing when you start talking
about them you guys are a
joke in that business you're a joke
and you're a nasty joke that has ripped
a bunch of people off to the tune of
billions of dollars and it's time you
stopped
so we're going to talk about you if
you're time
share scum so get ready going to be next
hour if you have had experience with
time sure scum and it didn't turn out
well for you
and you want to talk about it i'm going
to give you just the place to do it
right here you can call us at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five for next hour's show
or you can email if you can't get
through because the lines are jammed
right now
uh just go to dave on air at
ramseysolutions.com put timeshare scum
in the subject line
and uh we'll give you a chance to talk
and tell your story as to what happened
and
the time that they screwed you like they
have half of america
so there you go hope i wasn't unclear on
how
this is going to go down um it's not
like this is an objective thing
i'm right there's scum and we're going
to tell everybody it's how it's going to
work okay
so uh
dave on air at ramseysolutions.com john
starts off this hour in toronto hey john
what's up in your world
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can i help
uh so i'm 21 years old just graduated
from
school congratulations what's your
degree in
uh paramedicine good what are you gonna
be making
uh 40 bucks an hour good good for you
yeah so i have thank you i have about
twenty one thousand dollars
in loans about seven thousand dollars in
my savings
and the interest on the loan is only
about fifteen dollars a month
so i'm kind of wondering should i be
dumping 90 of my paycheck into
paying off my student loans or kind of
paying half on student loans and half
in the savings account kind of thing and
the savings account pays
nothing um it's just like a student
savings account right now so it's
nothing
i have to set up something better yeah
nothing
yeah and so we're going to not pay off
the student loans because they don't
charge a lot and we're going to save
money and make nothing
yeah that's pretty much what i'm doing
right now
[Laughter]
yeah so when you're 31 uh
i think you're going to be really glad
that i kicked your butt and told you to
pay off your student loans
immediately don't screw around with
these things
and here's the thing you're correct
mathematically and that the interest is
not that high
but there's another interest that you're
paying and it's the weight of them
hanging around your neck that makes you
even question the situation
you can feel the weight across the tops
of your shoulders and runs down your
back
and occasionally it manifests itself in
a headache yeah you have
a physical reaction to debt you have an
emotional reaction to debt you have a
spiritual reaction to debt that has
nothing to do with mathematics
but it does affect your life and the
quality of your life and you'll know
that i'm right about this
when you're free of it and you feel
light
and airy and wow i had no idea
this feels so nice the ritual's over the
poor
and the borrower is slave
to the lender when a slave is set free
they are free indeed so set yourself
free young man
as fast as you possibly can that's what
i would do
aaron is with us in denver hi erin
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you sir for having me um long time
listener
you've helped me get through a lot of
stuff in the past and hopefully you can
help with situation now thanks how can i
help today
yeah uh so 30 years old me and my wife
we're looking at selling our houses you
know the market here in denver is
pretty crazy we've got some pretty solid
equity in the house we have currently
upwards of 300 000
looking to buy a new house and we're
given a couple
options um from the lender that we're
working with and one of them i'm
extremely unfamiliar with i've owned
several houses traditionally done just a
fixed
interest mortgage they're offering me
what's called an
all-in-one loan and i just was curious
have you ever heard of that
good bad situation what what do you have
to say
i've not heard of it it does sound like
a brand particular to that
lender what does it entail
so how they're marketing it is it's
basically a savings account
that the balance in the account reduces
the interest
by that amount so you know we have about
fifty thousand dollars in cash that we
keep in the account at all times so
that would basically reduce the interest
that's charged on the account
the thing i don't like about it is it's
a variable interest rate right now it's
around three and a half
you know versus i can get a 1.99 on a
15-year fixed
um but it has potential to go up from
there it's kind of a sliding rate so
the math you know they provided me a
spreadsheet that said it'll save fifty
thousand dollars over the life of the
loan or something you know something
like that but
um it's just kind of a new territory too
yeah
if you put the fifty thousand dollars as
an extra down payment on the house
and you get out of debt that much faster
you're gonna make save a lot more than
their spreadsheet gave you
that's what i figured i'm an engineer so
i'm pretty good with math and i've tried
to
run a bunch of different scenarios and
ended up being awash basically and
here's the other thing
here's the other part of that is there's
there's a part of the math that's hard
to put
in there and it's the analysis of risk
that the more debt you have on the house
obviously the higher your payment is and
so the more risk you have the longer
you're in debt the more risk you have
and the higher the ratio of loan to
value is the higher your risk is
uh and that it's hard to put that to an
actual math figure but that's
common sense we know that to be true
because you and i have walking around
since right we know that if i owe more
money i have more risk
duh you know so uh but but it's hard to
actually put an
actual dollar figure to that with the
way we do see that play out in reality
and where we can measure it is like when
we did the the ramsey team did our
ramsey research
study on millionaires and we studied 10
000 millionaires
we didn't find a single one that used a
technique like you're talking about to
become wealthy not one
correct instead we found the typical
millionaire all the data tells us
that the typical millionaire quickly
gets out of debt average pays off their
home in 11.2 years
uh which means that some do it sooner
some do it longer but that was the
average among the 10
000 millionaires none of them were
sitting around going i'm going to figure
out a way
mathematically to borrow my own money
back and pay a little higher interest
rate on a variable
and spreadsheet says and you know all
this crap that they're telling you right
with this product so this product stinks
to high heaven dude run from it
bottom line you knew it you could feel
it in your bones but you hadn't figured
out way to put a math number to it yet
but i just gave it to you data says
don't do it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america this is
the ramsey show we're glad you're here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five if you live like no one else later
you can live and
give like no one else there's a price to
be paid for winning
no discipline seems pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
our team is just giving away my
best-selling stuff i mean this is crazy
next to nothing almost we are running an
epic two-day sale right now good
gracious that means you can get up to 80
percent
off books bundles and envelopes and give
a life-changing gift springtime
graduation
season wedding season father's day is
coming up you name it if you're ready
already budgeting and you know the baby
steps we want you to live
and give like no one else these sales
are great opportunities
to stock up on gifts for people that
really need it
two-day sale includes audio books
starting at five dollars oh my gosh
the starter envelope system for
budgeting only five dollars
bundles lots of the bundles on the site
up to 80
off and the update ramsay plus marriage
bundle
which includes now the know yourself
money assessment which we just launched
two weeks ago
man these are deals use this opportunity
to give and
live like no one else you may just
change someone's entire life
and if you're trying to get out of debt
well you can start right here
shop this epic two-day sale at
ramseysolutions.com
store ramsey solutions dot com
slash store alex is with us in new york
city hi alex welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
uh just a little background i graduated
college recently i have a full-time
job going and um i just wanna i have
minimal liabilities
the work from home situation and i want
to invest aggressively
uh as early as i can and i'm interested
in investing in
rental properties but as you know real
estate in this region is
you know astronomical so i was looking
into um
out of state our goods were you know my
money would be certain and
you know i have a better opportunity to
pay all cash for these rentals and i
just kind of want to get your thoughts
on that
what do you make uh 70 000
how old are you 22.
okay and so how much do you have saved
uh i'm about 40 000 saver now i don't
know the student ones that like
i i definitely plan to pay those off of
the check like
very very soon so it's about ten
thousand students
you live in manhattan
uh i live in new york area not not in
the end
where do you live um
i live in staten island okay all right
cool
all right i'm just trying to figure out
how you was making it on 70 grand dude
i mean i kind of know that market um
yeah
uh so it's a good income but it's a very
expensive place to live as you know even
staten island but nowhere near like
manhattan so
all right hey um
no look here here's the problem
and i own a bunch of real estate as you
probably know alex and i love real
estate as you probably know
and i've had really bad experiences
without a with rental properties that i
cannot lay my hands on
i need to be able to drive by them look
at them and even if someone else is
running them for me i i
you just make better decisions if
they're within
you know shooting distance here where
you can get to them um
it just sets you up for a problem and if
if you have a rental property that goes
bad
it could set you back more than
then three of them going good could set
you forward
and so that's the problem i you know
real estate requires it's got a hassle
factor to it as an investment
it requires involvement and uh no you
cannot just stand back and watch someone
else run it and it all work out
uh it just i mean you can have a
property manager and there are some
good property managers but no one
manages your stuff like you do so you've
got to look over the shoulder of the
property manager to be sure that things
are being done right and go
how much did we pay for that hot water
eater say what
you know that kind of stuff and you got
to have you know and when that's
three four hours away from you or eight
hours away from you or something
that just becomes very tenuous and it
sets you up for a high potential to have
a bad experience in real estate rather
than a good one
so i would tell you not to do that i
would tell you instead let's just pile
up our money
and and let's see where your career
takes you and see where you end up
landing
and let's just start investing i would
just use mutual funds at your age to
begin to build it up you don't have
enough to buy it anyway today so it
doesn't matter it's all theory at this
point
uh chris is in houston hi chris welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave it's an honor to speak to you
thanks for having me sure what's up
hey my wife and i our family we're in
baby steps four five and six
we've got a fully funded emergency fund
of 30 000
and the household that we live in has
natural gas
and electricity energy sources so does
not keep getting
but i keep getting letters in the mail
from our natural gas
provider stating that any pipelines that
run exterior to the house we would be
responsible for
100 out of pocket for any repair
or burst and they're offering a plan
for eight bucks a month that would um
supply
up to um and eight thousand dollar
um policy coverage i bet i was wondering
um if that would be
a good idea to do absolutely not that's
horrible
okay that's what i thought but i this is
the first household that we've ever
lived in with natural gas and
electricity so
i just want to get your perspective yeah
they're making a bazillion dollars on
that they're making more on that crap
than they are on gas
oh my god that's what i thought yeah so
let me kind of here's
here's how i'm answering that question
with such in with such emotion okay
um in my life which i'm old
i've owned over 2 000 pieces of real
estate
lots and lots of residential
single-family homes are on that list
i used to buy property that was trashed
fix it up and resell it in my twenties
and flip it in all of those pieces of
property i have replaced plumbing
and lots of them i've replaced i've had
septic tank problems
with lots of them i've had sewer lines
running from the street that got busted
up by roots from a tree growing next to
them
in lots of them lots of them not
hundreds but enough of them that i
remember it
happening a lot okay i've bought houses
that the wiring was bad in and we had to
strip it out and put all
wiring back yeah in all of those
properties
and i'm in middle tennessee and natural
gas is very proper
or are very prevalent in middle
tennessee you'll see it in a lot of our
homes i have it in my personal home now
i have it in my lake house now okay
right here in middle tennessee so it's
natural gas is everywhere where i'm
doing all these deals
the vast majority of these houses would
have had natural gas in them the number
of times
i have replaced a natural gas line from
the street
to the house out of all of those
different experiences is zero
oh wow okay beautiful so there's
actually some data behind my
going no way right
yeah so that's what i thought too but i
mean i'd be more likely to buy sewer
line experience
sewer line insurance than i would be gas
line insurance and they don't know they
don't sell that that i know of so
um yeah that that's interesting god what
will they come up with
next to sell people unbelievable hey
thanks for calling that's very
interesting i appreciate that question
the first time i've ever had that
question i didn't even know they did
that
that's why so here's a good rule to
remember on insurance of all kinds
extended warranties of all kinds
some insurance is ensuring something
that's so expensive that you cannot
afford to fix it
your house burning down your car being
totaled
you die and your family loses your
income
these are major life-altering huge
expensive things and you do need to buy
insurance
for life insurance homeowners insurance
car insurance to transfer the risk that
you cannot afford to take
small items like a gas line from the
street
like getting an extended warranty at
best buy
on your big screen give me a break
which is a throwaway item anyway by the
way so
no you don't buy those insurances
because that's where they make all their
money
you only buy insurance on things that
are large and that you need to transfer
the risk that you can't afford to take
the hit
that's a good rule of thumb right there
so the next time someone wants to do
extended warranty say
no thank you and you can blame it on me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america open
phones this hour triple eight eight two
five
five two two five in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt-free stage
tim and shannon are with us hey guys how
are you
great dave thanks for having us
absolutely where do you guys live
suburb of chicago illinois okay
wonderful so good to have you and how
much have you paid off
we've paid off 60 67 000
um and that took about 10 months good
for you guys
and your range of income during that
time was one uh 175
good what do y'all do for a living i'm a
police officer uh-huh
and i work in hr all right very cool
what kind of debt was the 67
000 a lot of normal stuff um
we had some credit cards there may have
been an engagement ring in there
might have been um yeah and uh we had
car loan
and student loans okay it's kind of
normal yeah how long you been married
we got married the end of october okay
so yeah about seven months almost so you
were working on this before marriage
we were we kept it separate we followed
the principles everything until we got
married and then we put it together and
power became that and finished it up yes
sir yeah
very good so tell me the story how did
you get started on all this
so i got to give a little shout out to
uh my employer the village of algonquin
covet hit uh sat down with our chief of
police
um i'm the training supervisor for our
law enforcement agency
we said uh let's bring smart dollar to
the police officers wow
yep thank you so uh we instituted smart
dollar
uh went strictly for them and i had to
go through the program
first before i rolled it out to
everybody else sure so i did it
loved it fell in love had never really
heard from me before and i did exactly
what you said not to do i went home
and told shannon sit down we're doing
this and tried to shove it down her
throat and that didn't go well
but i taught you that in training school
did they they did they did
so reeled back though um we ended up
going through smart dollar together
and just fell in love it all made sense
it all made sense we realized
we were paycheck to paycheck we made way
too much money for that to happen
yeah for those of you out there that
don't know smart dollar is our program
that corporate america and some
government agencies
take in to make all of the financial
peace stuff and all the
every dollar stuff available to their
team members like costco has had their
entire
company go through it as an example and
obviously your wonderful police
department went through it yeah thank
you guys very much for that
and it's called smart dollar it's a
different brand because it's in
corporate america
and so that's why you don't always hear
about it on the show very cool
all right so shannon he comes in and
screws this thing up what did you do you
said you got to be kidding me a little
bit yeah
and then how did he finally get you back
around after he screwed that up
for me um it was once i understood more
so
the the underlying reason why he wanted
to shove it down my throat
i knew he was really you know just
trying to be caring and
as we were getting ready to prepare life
as a married couple
i know oftentimes people struggle
financially
in marriages and then that tends yeah so
that was really important um so i know
he he came from a loving standpoint so i
think once i reframed
why he was trying to shove it down my
throat so much made more sense and
yeah i ended up um purchasing the total
money makeover without him knowing
i know i tried to take some initiative
wow
and did some plastic surgery um like 48
hours after i
binged uh your books wow oh yeah cut it
all up
so when you get in you get you got all
the way in then all right so once once
once
we got past that initial hurdle then
we're we're joining forces and going for
it
very very cool we drank the kool-aid
good and you did it i mean you're
professionals you paid off 67
000 worth and in addition to that i'm
sorry
uh we also cash flowed about um
additional
fourteen thousand dollars for our
coveted wedding
um and thank you and to the other ramsey
personalities who said why wait until
you know
why why push the wedding off because of
covid so because of you guys we actually
got married
a lot sooner than we anticipated so um
yeah yeah it was yeah so we cashflowed
the wedding cash flowed part of a
graduate degree so that was all besides
the 67 so we were really
going after it for a while yeah you were
you make good money but you were really
you you made
you also made really good decisions yeah
we were fortunate that we had a large
shovel but
um yeah the discipline still needed to
be there
oh yeah you've got to be intentional
just the same yes sir yeah very cool
well so as an hr director now you've got
to take smart dollar to your place right
oh my gosh i would love nothing more
than to do that we're still working on
that but i
yes one day hopefully sometimes it's a
challenge
very cool guys very cool so you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
what now
for me it was the budget um i
am the nerd in the relationship mm-hmm
so and that was one thing to where i
mean
we didn't spend anything but i'm
checking it every day it's like
something was going to change but it
didn't
to see the numbers to see where
everything added up that really made
sense
we nerds get comfort in numbers that
don't change correct
correct i knew i didn't spend anything
yesterday but i need to check it again
today to make sure we're still good
still i'm good with that nothing
happened but it was the budget but then
it was for me it was additionally it was
just
the why and knowing that we were going
into a young marriage
um being on the same page you know it
was our counseling per se our premarital
counseling that's recommended by you and
just put it all together it was like hey
we're on the same page we can do
anything
wow yeah very cool and i think saying no
is also probably one of the most
challenging
hurdles through this whole process so
learning to just
you know internally when to say no to
yourself that's probably the hardest
piece that uh it's a weird thing it um
it's very difficult when you do it but
it's very satisfying a day later
a hundred percent it's the discipline
that came along
oh yeah and everybody's journey was
different but covet actually
our vice was eating out all the time oh
yeah didn't have that option up by us
we saved a bunch of money there and it
was just one thing after the other and
it was snowballed into something
beautiful
yeah that's that's interesting yeah and
it's it's
you know it's not saying no forever it's
saying no for a little while uh
live like no one else so that later you
can live and give like no one else now
you have no debt and you make a
ton of money what are you going to do
next
well just haven't been married you know
we have a family in the future
we got lots of other plans and you know
really we could do anything we want now
yeah yeah
i mean it's amazing where you are this
is very cool plus you have this sense
that we can do anything
because you just did a big thing yes
during a very difficult time
correct i mean you plowed through and
knocked it out very cool
what was the uh who were your biggest
cheerleaders
each other i know for a fact we held
each other accountable
that was huge it's do do we need to do
this do we need to spend that well no
did you check the budget so it started
internally and
the reminders on the why um helped but
then
um for me at least going to work every
day knowing everybody else was working
the smart dollar program some took it
more serious than other
and you know um i was also the one
keeping track of everybody's progress in
a sense
but um that really helped and as well
our other good friends uh
that turned us on to you a while ago uh
teddy and stephanie crawford back in
chicagoland area they were the ones that
had all the positive words of wisdom and
everything throughout
you got to have those yes that's very
cool yeah so as the trainer you were
getting the overall report not
individual
individual things but you said saw what
the whole police department was seeing
correct
we don't get into their you know we
don't get their finances or anything but
it's the point system to know who's
engaging watching your lessons
uh the baby steps are obviously included
so we had people working those
um and you're seeing overall progress as
well overall progress we're getting
feedback and that was the conversation
we had with the chief and the village
manager hey did it work the first year
do we want it again this year
yeah thumbs up across the board oh wow
thanks
very cool i'm glad it worked that's a
big thing and thanks for what you do
excellent job tim and shannon chicago
illinois we got a copy of the legacy
journey our latest book about wealth
that i wrote anyway
latest book i wrote and uh and an extra
copy of the total money makeover for you
to give away so you can pay it forward
so
good good stuff tim and shannon chicago
67 000 paid off in 10 months making 175
between them count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
that's how it's done boom
man how cool is that the whole police
department gets the whole thing going
new married couple gets it going this is
just good stuff right here
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome to the ramsey show i'm dave
ramsey your host open phones a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
margie's with us
in seattle hi margie how are you
hi i'm good good how can i help
um we're on baby step two and
um my husband got served with his
summons for a bad debt
um and so after talking to some debt
relief
attorneys uh like four of them they
suggested
bankruptcy
okay and
we're about 33
34 000 in debt and credit cards and we
have like a
11 000 loan on our car
and about a hundred thousand dollars
worth of student loans combined
okay and and what's your household
income
um about 28 000 a year
okay who's not working me
why um
my daughter is at home um
with cold it and everything and my
anxiety
your daughter is how old seven
[Music]
and are you being treated for your
anxiety yes
okay in what way
therapy
[Music]
yes okay all right
well let me give you a couple of facts
that we can walk through
and then let's try to figure out how to
help you okay
okay fact number one student loans are
not bankruptable
okay yes i know so after bankruptcy you
will still have a hundred thousand
dollars in student loan debt
fact number two your household income is
twenty eight thousand dollars
y'all are starving to death
and bankruptcy will not fix your income
problems
okay so after bankruptcy
we get rid of credit card debt and by
the way you don't have a car anymore
or you still have a car payment one of
the two
if you don't give up the car you still
got the eleven thousand dollars in car
so really when it gets down to it if
you're going to keep the car and
reaffirm it it's called in a chapter
seven bankruptcy
then you would have thirty three
thousand dollars in credit card that is
all you're bankrupting
yes and who served you
um which credit card
um the credit card was to credit one
bank
okay and how much do you owe them a
thousand and six dollars
okay all right um
all right the third fact is that debt
relief attorneys
are generally not debt relief attorneys
generally what they are as bankruptcy
attorneys
and if you ask a bankruptcy attorney if
you're bankrupt that's like asking a dog
if it's hungry
yeah so the advice you were getting from
a
quote-unquote professional was
self-serving advice on their part
so these are the things that are
disturbing me
and and you know so we're getting advice
from
people that are you know want you to
file bankruptcy because it's what they
do
you know they're a hammer so
everything's a nail um
if you're going to keep the car we're
not filing bankruptcy on very much and
really
1 000 is all that's triggering this
and you have a household income of 28
000 which is
less than half the annual income of the
typical household in america
and so i'm not shaming you i'm just
saying you guys have an income
issue i've been there myself one year in
my life i made six thousand dollars okay
so i know how it feels it ain't no fun
what's your husband do for a living
um he works at a car dealership
doing what reporters um driving cars
driving cars 40 hours a week
um well on average right now
33. yeah and how old are you guys
in our 40s okay all right
and so for me to help you have a good
life
a decade from now i want to be able to
paint a picture
that gets rid of not only the immediate
stress of this lawsuit
but also gets rid of a hundred thousand
dollars worth of student loan debt
and allows you all to have the freedom
can you imagine can you even
for a second wrap your brain around what
it would feel like in your home
if you guys made sixty thousand dollars
a year and had no debt
i can i envision it yeah that's where i
want you to go
and that's where my mind takes me on
answering your question when you
when i start gathering the pieces of
information up
but there's a lot of things that are
going to have to happen for
us to live that dream together okay
and i i am not a mental health
professional and i do know that anxiety
is real and i am not
uh qualified to tell you when and if you
can go back to work or what you could do
but i am qualified to tell you that your
family needs income
and i am qualified to tell you 33 hours
a week is not enough to work when your
family is just broke your husband needs
to get six more jobs
especially since the one he has kind of
sucks
is that me and mean no
but i mean it's a step up from where he
was before so that's good
then he needs to take let's take two
more steps up because
he's in his 40s and when he's in his 50s
i don't want him making 28 000
a year driving cars do you
no okay then we have to we have to
intentionally take some steps
up from here and part of that's cleaning
off this debt
who's got these degrees with a hundred
thousand dollars worth of debt
none of us what did you study
um i did accounting um
and i transferred school so my credits
didn't transfer
so i had to start all over and so that's
kind of made it difficult at one point
and what was the last job that you had
um
[Music]
administrative assistant okay have you
ever done accounting
in the vote as a vocation
yes okay what did what did you do
um as an administrative assistant i did
um partial accounting you helped them
keep the books
yeah yeah good okay because you do know
how to do it you just didn't finish with
the degree
yeah good good okay so there's a
possibility you start doing
accounting for some small businesses in
the area
as you're working for yourself and doing
that from home where you can keep your
anxiety low
maybe yeah i've been looking for
work from home okay um career is it the
going out thing that gives you anxiety
what gives you anxiety um
well a ton of things but um as for me
getting a job
it's more of the like i'm afraid of
letting them down
uh like not being able to show up okay
i understand oh i see so if you had a uh
an anxiety attack in the morning and
weren't able to go to work then you'd
feel bad about letting them down and
probably get fired eventually for doing
that right yeah
yeah okay well that makes sense has that
happened before
um well it's happened where i haven't
been able to
um go out no but did lu you lost your
job as a result
no no my anxiety came after
after i stopped working oh after you
stopped working
hmm yeah that's interesting
okay i don't know anything i mean
dr john dolone is not here to help me
with this so i'm kind of trying to
channel my
inner dr d here but the um
uh because i i know that what you're
facing is real i do know that
and i'm not questioning that but i'm
trying to figure out a way to get you
guys some income coming in so i would
prescribe
no you're not bankrupt just ignore this
lawsuit they're not going to do anything
what are they going to garnish your
wages he's making money
they're not going to do anything just
ignore them and move on i
know i would not file bankruptcy i will
put you guys into ramsey
plus for a year i'll pay for it let's
put you into financial peace university
get you on a budget
uh but then you're all part of it is
you've got to do some stuff to get your
household income up or you're not going
to make it
this is the ramsey show hold on
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone
browse by topic or even sync clips to
your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice we're
going to spend this hour talking about
the scummiest
business in america today
the time share industry
[Music]
probably a close second would be payday
lenders
and we could put another p group of
people or two in the list but these are
the scum of the scum this is the lowest
of the low
they feed on people they take advantage
of people basically they screw
you the consumer everybody seems to know
it but for some reason everybody keeps
playing with the tiger
i don't know why you keep playing with
the tiger
you go to the resort
and diamond or windham
or westgate or marriott invites you for
a free night on the beach a free night
in vegas a free night wherever
or two but in return you have to give up
five hours of your life
in a timeshare meeting if you leave the
meeting one minute early before
they give you permission to you have to
pay for your room so everyone seems to
endure it
but this is this is what you do i don't
understand why you
do this and so i'm going to try to
convince you to stop doing this
you go into this meeting this is like
going this is like saying
the zoo calls you up and says we will
give you a one-year pass to the zoo
if you will spend an hour in the cage
with the tiger petting it
but we need to warn you ahead of time
that the tiger's not eating in several
days and he's rather greedy
and so you go in and say well i'm the
one that will be able to pet the tiger
and not get eaten
so that i can get a free pass to the zoo
it ain't
worth it buy yourself a hotel room
and don't go in the tiger cage
but you do and then you spend twenty two
thousand dollars fourteen thousand
dollars twenty eight thousand dollars
and you mortgage air
because you don't own anything
except access to their hotel room
for a week maybe if you can get in
and then maybe you pay cash for it which
is even worse
because now you own air officially
that's paid off and you have abs and
then you find out that they're going to
raise your annual fees all the time
these people are straight up scum
this is a horrible product 97
of the people that buy a timeshare don't
like their timeshare
wish they hadn't done it have regrets
would like to get out of it
they think that the timeshare business
like diamond and wyndham and marriott
and westgate sucks they think
they screwed me and they're a little bit
ashamed to tell their friends that they
got screwed
by these people because they feel so
dumb for going in the tiger cage
because you go all along i knew they
were screwing me but i still
i just didn't have the wherewithal to
say no enough times in
five hours with the temperature cranked
up to 82 degrees and they were
waterboarding me
they put you in a torture chamber and
won't let you out i mean you have to be
like
a ba to bust out of there man
you got to be just arrogant and angry to
get away from these people once you
put yourself in one of those rooms
consequently the timeshare business has
been sued and sued and sued and sued and
sued and lost and lost and lost and lost
and lost and lost
catherine says in 2013 we were visiting
the cancun resort in las vegas when we
were told that diamond resorts
which has now been purchased by hilton
had taken over the membership that we
had in two different timeshare companies
we were asked to attend a meeting
again where the sales staff told us that
we needed to make a purchase so that we
could continue to keep the
equity we had already built up over the
past 10 years what equity timeshares are
worthless especially diamonds
since that meeting we've been subjected
to numerous update meetings
where we've been pressured to the point
where we felt we needed to make a
purchase to be able to leave the room
every time we told the staff we were
already unhappy and that we could not
afford to make another purchase yet
again they assured us that with the new
purchase all of our problems would be
solved
we tried to solve this with diamond and
their representatives to no avail we
feel we have been continuously preyed
upon
by diamond resorts stay away
john says last march we drove from our
home in michigan to florida but our
reservations were canceled due to the
pandemic
after that we heard nothing during the
summer we realized that the virus was
continuing to be a problem and we would
not feel comfortable to travel or stay
in a resort we began calling and writing
letters to windham
asking them to consider extending our
vip points into 2021 because of the
unusual circumstances
on december 1st we were finally informed
that we would not
they would not and our points would
terminate at the end of the year
we are also reminded that we could not
make guest reservations meaning that we
would have to use it personally
we have been cheated out of the third
year of our contract because of the
pandemic
and wyndham refused to recognize that
the pandemic called for concessions we
were vip members for
20 years we now have a very negative
impression of wyndham
and will never encourage anyone to deal
with them in any way
even for a one-night hotel stay
windham by the way is spending a hundred
million dollars purchasing travel and
leisure
and a rebranding from windom to travel
and leisure
and windham is a nationally known brand
internationally known brand
but they're going to do completely away
with it you know why
and they're spending 100 million dollars
to do away with this nationally known
brand
why because it has so much negative
connotation attached to it now
because they've screwed so many people
why is this hard to figure out mario's
not far behind marriott vacation club
sales people
are super trained used car sales people
they tell you how easy it looks and how
easy it is to book trust me it's all
fabrication
i could not book a week in october 11
months in advance costs how about 20 000
for your week of time share 750 for
annual maintenance fees 104
to trade week for points ninety nine
dollars for interval membership eighty
four dollars to book your week and oh
yeah
seventy nine dollars to cancel your week
after canceling even due to death and
immediate family you have 60 days to use
your week at a resort
good luck with that because you can't
book it check the figures
booking fancy hotels is much cheaper
and you don't have to stay a full week
in the same location and you get the
week you want without booking a full
year in advance
stay away from marriott vacation clubs
trust me
signed a true sucker
these are actual posts on the internet
right now
in the last few weeks if you've been
screwed
by the timeshare industry and you want
to talk about it this hour that's what
we're going to do baby
we want to expose these crooks for who
they are
the phone number here is triple eight
eight two five five
two two five and you can't get out of
them they're almost impossible to get
out of oh well we'll release them
horse crap you will not now you lied
again
unbelievable you're not releasing
anybody
you screw them and then you hold them
and screw them over and over and over
again
it's unbelievable it's a shameful thing
that you're doing
and you continue to do it diamond
marriott
windham westgate the worst offenders if
you have an offender of another
type that's fine or if you just want to
talk about one of those that you've
worked for
and you quit because you got tired of
screwing people
call me 825-5225
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
we're talking about the time share
industry today one of the scummiest
[Music]
of all industries multi-billion dollars
and boy do they throw their dollars and
their weight around
they try to crush anyone who comes
against them they've been
having a fit with me i can tell you that
and uh
and all they've done is just piss me off
instead of silence me
so i'll tell you a little bit more about
that later if you have
been a victim of timeshares or you own a
timeshare or you used to work for them
and you got tired of screwing people so
you got out of there
and you want to tell what really goes on
behind the scenes we all know but
love to hear from you the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five
two two five hal's got a horror story
he's in evansville
hey hal how are you i'm doing fine you
dave
good man tell me your story good
well uh we bought back in the early 90s
uh at westgate in florida and uh
you know you talk about them strong
strong arming you into buying
it wasn't really like that for us they
what they said made sense to us at first
and and so we bought
and we used it once or twice every you
know a few years
and just we decided it was time to get
out of it would you please
we tried and tried and and nothing that
we said well they said that just
yes how would you pay for it uh it's
about 20 000.
okay and so you used it a couple of
times every every two or three years
and then after how many dave ramsey is
one of the worst uh
investments i ever made in my life and
after
after how many years of using it a
couple times every few years that did
you want to get out
oh i after the first five years we were
trying
we decided to try to get out of it so
you had used it maybe ten times
no not even that probably five times
okay for twenty thousand dollars and you
wanted to get out and what
what happened well they said they do not
uh
uh buy them back they suggested that i
either try to rent it or give it away to
someone which is a joke too because
you know no people that have heard about
them know that that's not a good
investment and
no you can't give them away and so
if you can't give it away it's not an
investment at all
exactly okay and there is no re uh
resale market for these at all
no you can you can go online and agree
and look at what they are
okay you can't even sell them for a
dollar because people don't want to take
over the dadgum fees
exactly and then uh two about three
years ago they hit us with
a uh a thousand dollar uh special
assessment
i guess we're gonna do some painting and
uh they
so that you know there's nothing you can
do about that either you know that's on
top of what you're paying for
maintenance and taxes every year
and so when about three years ago when i
was diagnosed with cancer
for the second time uh two weeks after
my wife was diagnosed with cancer
i decided it was time to really start in
earnest trying to get out of this thing
so
i made some contacts and started
networking with people
who were sympathetic with my situation
and
they referred me to an attorney who
tried to help us the best she could
and i ended up on a witness list in a
lawsuit that that she was involved in
and that was really when uh when
westgate took notice when they saw my
deposition and saw how damaging my
testimony could be
uh out of the blue one day they just
called me and said uh i hear you want to
get out of your timeshare here
sign these documents and you're done
that's how i got out i wish it was that
easy for everybody but it's not
right so you had good you had to get
their attention by punching them in the
nose in other words
pretty much so you call them up and go
i've got cancer my wife's got cancer and
they said toughies
exactly yeah and that and it wasn't that
easy because it took me
uh sitting on hold for 30 minutes uh you
know waiting for someone to come online
to
to even talk to me and that was i wasted
a lot of time on the phone but it was
worth it in the end because i did get
out but
my poor dad has been has been dead for
12 years and i still get a bill every
year for his maintenance and taxes
and i hope you don't pay that oh no no
no no no
but they and i called him and told him
that you know he's deceased his estate
has been settled for two years
and they don't care they just keep
sending a bill
so i keep throwing in the trash yeah so
wow
so where was this property uh we bought
in uh
uh orlando at uh it's westgate it was
because it was at the west gate of
disney
ah that's where it was named oh and uh
that's where the company was named i bet
huh
yes yes because they've got them all
over now i mean they screw people in
lots of towns now
yes they do yes they do and we uh we're
a little closer to
branson missouri so we traded
for a another additional fee they they
allowed us to trade to
that property uh about 10 years ago
and uh so it was closer for us we did
use that one a little bit more because
we could drive to that one
but uh it was still uh we just didn't
use it
and once we decided that we would uh
much rather spend our time
uh doing other things and and you're
right you know
if you want to change uh locations
they'll let you do it
for a fee it's 150 to change or even to
change the week that you go
yeah they'll nickel and dime you to
death yeah yeah
and now a thousand dollars to paint it
yeah that comes up after you've already
paid 22 000 for it and used it five
times
or twenty that was probably the straw
that broke the camel's back was when we
got that special assessment so how are
you your wife's cancer how y'all doing
we're doing great so you both recovered
yes good and like i said i was i've i've
had cancer twice
and beat it both times so praise the
lord for that one
amen wow well i'm glad you're doing
better i'm sorry
for your situation but i appreciate you
taking time and telling
22 million people westgate will screw
you and even if you've got cancer they
basically just hang up on you
and they're not going to get out of it
until you get involved in a lawsuit
against them and then suddenly they go
oh you said you want it out who knew
which is exactly how all these guys act
it's the only way you get out is you
have to pound their face in
because they're absolute scum hope i
haven't been unclear you guys
all right sandy's with us in hayes
kansas
hey sandy tell me your story about time
shares
well hi dave we were in florida in 1999
with our daughter who was actually
cheering for hayes at a collegiate um
competition down there
and we were walking down the beach and
the man came up and offered us a place
to have some
um free drinks and some stuff inside of
the hotel and
offered the girls a free bicycle rental
and everything and so we went in and
kind of got caught that way we um
we had in much that day even though we
had made
up our minds before we went in we were
showing you how that goes
and um we ended up the
previous caller spent a lot more money
than we did we ended up buying in for
only six thousand dollars but
their way to get us to buy was by
explaining to us that
other people had to buy a week at a time
and this time sure was done by points
so we didn't ever buy a week we didn't
buy a specific time
frame we could go anytime and they would
buy it back from us
anytime we wanted to get rid of it and
so
that wasn't in writing was no
well actually it was it was in writing
it was
uh you're cutting in and out honey
you're going to speak directly into your
phone
sandy you're cutting in and out you're
going to speak directly into your phone
okay i'm sorry that's okay so we you
said it was in writing that they would
buy it back
yes it was in writing and when we got
ready to try to sell it back to them
then
they explained to us that sun tara had
been bought out by
diamond and diamond
didn't have an agreement and so it was
no longer
it was mullenbloid and i asked him i
said so you can change the contrast
without even telling us if you're
diamonds you can because diamond is god
that's exactly what they implied to us
that they
were pretty much the end-all deal and
they even told us
when i we asked them nicely to buy it
back
i'm thinking that that was what we'd
signed up for
and um the guy told us he said you know
we will take you to court for the rest
of your life we will ruin your credit
we will take your home we'll take
everything but you cannot get out of
this
there is no way and so we just kind of
gave up for another year or so
and then i started look while seeing a
lot of
ads for it and we were afraid to be
scammed again
so we kind of just didn't do anything
until i saw an ad for
the time share exit team which had your
your name
um behind it and they got you out of it
very confident
you guys got us out of it i'm not tom
sharrick's a team time sheriff's a team
got you out of no time
yes they did awesome that's cool well at
least you got loose from
diamond that's that's like man
that's like getting loose from a
concentration camp
[Music]
so
[Music]
we're talking about the out-of-control
multi-billion dollar
scummy timeshare industry
screwing people left and right and
getting away with it and nobody's in
their face about it
they're buying off government officials
they're buying off
media they're buying off everything
trying to do this
they've been after us trying to shut us
up and it's not going to work as a
matter of fact you're getting quite the
opposite reaction i'm going to devote
entire hours
to pissing these people off because now
they piss me off so it's a fair trade
this from andrew about diamond resorts
which was just purchased by hilton the
ceo is a guy named mike
flasky now mike mikey i call him
mikey and i've been trading barbs he
calls me davey
uh on on twitter a time or two back and
forth
he stood up in front of the arda which
is the timeshare association and said he
was going to pledge a million dollars
this year
to putting any timeshare exit people out
of business
how dare someone try to get out of their
timeshare
after we've screwed them in other words
my wife and i were in las vegas when we
were approached by diamond resorts
representatives asking if we'd be
interested in receiving free tickets to
dinner in a show
as a gift for our attendance to a one
hour
presentation when we signed up our
yearly income did not meet their minimum
but the rep said don't worry
which in hindsight should have been a
huge red flag no honey
a one hour presentation for the
timeshare company should have been a one
it should have been a red flag because
they're usually eight hours
at the presentation when the first offer
was presented we told them
no way we could afford it after four
hours there it is of continuous better
and one day only offers we finally gave
in the employees led us to believe it
would be an investment
for us and our family if you sell
timeshares by the way you're scum
you should get a better job you should
not be involved in screwing people and
if you don't like me saying that
that's because you're scum if you
understand that i'm saying that
you need to start looking for a job
today doing something that's honorable
the employees led us to believe this
would be an investment for us and our
family the one time we've used this
membership we could not make
reservations in hawaii
like we desired and we ended up in vegas
a little trade-off there
both have sand uh we forced us into a
mandatory member presentation where we
were talked into upgrading
since the representative told us we
could not refinance or we could
refinance with our bank at a lower rate
we relented this is not possible you
can't refinance at your bank because we
don't own anything
now we're stuck with something we cannot
afford and diamond
will not help us
but if you're one of the few attorneys
in america that will go
and represent the consumer against the
timeshare industry they will come after
you
they'll come after you the attorney
christian is on the line
he is in orlando he is an attorney and
he works
with other attorneys who've been sued
for trying to get people out of their
timeshares is that right did i say that
right
you did you got it dave and thank you
for everything you're doing
what in the world so you have people
that are
in the legal profession that are lawyers
that sue
a time share company to get people out
of their contracts
to abide by their contracts in some
cases which lets people out
and then they turn around and sue the
lawyer
these i'm sorry you cut out on me you
cut out on me try it again
sorry about that babe right now yes sir
i am
these timeshare companies don't want
lawyers talking to them
about arbitration or resolving things
all they want is for time share owners
to shut up and have
annual maintenance fees doubled every
year
and my clients are just lawyers who
they recognize that timeshare industry
is the last legal fraud
in america and now they're being shaken
down in federal court
these the big guys you said it i mean
they're weaponizing the courts
to shake down lawyers who help people
get out of the last legal fraud in
america it's shocking
wow and so you turn around and
you turn around and rep your client or
other attorneys who are trying to get
people out
that's right i represent how has that
grown how many of these cases have you
done and how is the
what's your success rate i i
currently have probably 15 cases
going on in state and federal court
most of these cases haven't resolved we
haven't even gotten to a trial
you know why we haven't gotten to a
trial dave because they want to beat you
to death financially
boom you got it they want to drag out
the billable hours until you dry up and
die
they want to make these guys spend
hundreds of thousands or millions of
dollars defending themselves
the the insurance companies don't want
to pick up the tab
you know and so they force them out of
business
through litigation and it's sham
litigation
they're not investigating these lawyers
ahead of time to see if they're good or
bad
my guys in missouri they were they just
have these salacious allegations
and it puts them out of business dave we
did they lose their law practice because
they can't afford to contin
continue to defend themselves against
this company who has infinitely deep
pockets oh by the way their pockets were
lined by people they screwed
and they're desperate to keep them lined
my clients are just
folks who they haven't given up yet you
know they haven't
given up they're not settling they keep
going in fact we filed a counter claim
against
windham and blue green for antitrust
and this morning we asked a judge to
enjoy
these guys from continuing any other
lawsuits against my client
until we resolve whether the arda
and their buddies windham diamond blue
green
did a concerted conspiracy antitrust
designed to make themselves stronger and
to screw the consumers we think that's
exactly what they've done
they announced it from the stage mike
flasky
the ceo of diamond announced that he was
putting up a million dollars and
challenged the other people in the arda
to come together and collude
to run exeters out of business
and and if the ftc isn't going to look
at it that means we have to so that's
what we're doing
wow i'm a little shocked i i have a
a a huge respect for federal judges and
i'm a little shocked they're tolerating
this in their courts
dave i don't think they are you know
although it's they
they started this antitrust stuff
probably about two or three years ago
like really going at it but i've noticed
in the last six months
these federal judges like you said
they're sharp and
they're the tide is turning you can tell
there's little orders that are coming
out
like i told you none of these have
really been resolved yet but the little
orders that are coming out they're
starting to note
that the dockets are being flooded with
these cases that seem to go on forever
and
ever and in the few cases that have had
a summary judgment
granted or something like that it's
usually in the favor
of the good guys so i think but that's
after they've dropped 200 000
or they didn't have and legal fees into
the thing the good guy you're right
you're right you're right and so it's
going to take one
someone maybe my clients maybe someone
else to give them a bloody nose and show
them that this frivolous litigation
can't stand
and i think we will yeah well
they've come after us now and that was a
mistake because i have deep enough
pockets to fight them
and i have 22 million listeners and i'm
gonna beat the snot out of them
picking on you wouldn't be my idea of a
good time well they did and it was a
mistake
they sent inside addition to do an
ambush
in the lobby of the hotel where we were
doing an event
last week and mary guerrero and charlie
mckelvie come in there which are known
for their intelligence anyway
but they do one of these ambush
interviews mr ramsey mr ramsey why are
you endorsing timeshare exit team
mr ramsey and ambush me in the front of
the dadgum lobby of this hotel but
there's no way inside edition does that
without these bozos causing it
yeah because inside edition's not that
smart to start with
mary's not that smart for sure okay
i mean she's not known for her brains
she's known for other stuff
but oh my gosh y'all this is what's
going on out there
yeah so i get i get you're going to see
me on a duck and cover in one of these
dadgum inside edition things coming up
this weekend probably
but unbelievable hey man thank you for
calling
thanks for talking to us i'm going to
tell you guys a story in this next
segment
it's going to blow your minds it goes
right with what christian's saying
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're talking about the scummy and
multi-billion dollar
timeshare industry who flexes its muscle
against anyone who dares say
that they're screwing people the way
they are
so i've been dealing with anything that
causes you guys grief
for 30 years here on the radio and if we
find something that gives you grief we
try to help you
with it if term life insurance is the
way to go we try to find a term
insurance provider for you
if getting a high quality real estate
agent is a good thing we try to do that
for you we do not
endorse things on this show unless we
believe in them i don't put my name or
my voice on something merely
for money and i that the most successful
endorsements that we've done on this
show
are things that have to do with a
problem you have and we connect you with
someone
that is an advertiser to solve that one
of the biggest problems we've run into
over the years is people that are stuck
in time shares you can't give them away
nobody wants them you can't sell them
even for a dollar because nobody wants
to take over your fees and your
increased fees and all the hassles and
all the screw-ups
that we've been hearing about this
entire hour
so many years ago a couple of young guys
started a company called timeshare exit
team
and they were advertising on a small
radio station or two here or there
and they got in touch with us and said
we want to come on the dave ramsey show
because you hate time shares as much as
we do and we have a way to get people
out of time shares
we have a legal process with a team of
lawyers
to bust up into these guys and to get
them out
and so we said all right let's do that
however you guys are small operators and
you need to understand when we tell
people to come to you
you're going to get a bunch of business
and you're going to get your business
act together
to say that their business exploded when
i came on the air and told people
timeshare exit team will get you out
is an understatement their business
skyrocketed over the next few years
resulting in them getting more than 20
000 almost 25 000 people out of their
timeshares
but the problem was
they were so successful that two things
happened
one is they're two young guys running a
business and it's hard to scale a
business that fast and they got where
they weren't returning calls that great
so we're jumping on them
because we're hearing complaints because
timeshare won't call us back timeshare
won't call us back from the customer
that's not okay and it was just because
of sheer volume of business
the second thing that happened was that
they were so successful
that the timeshare companies they were
feeling the pain
it was hurting them and so mike flasky
the ceo
of diamond which has just recently been
bought by hilton windham
mike flasky stands up in front of the
arda and says i'm going to commit a
million dollars to putting timeshare
exit companies out of business anyone
who comes at us to get our cut to make
us let our customers go
that we're screwing we're going to put
them out of business
we're going to do it with legal fees
we're going to do it with pr and
publicity we're hiring a publicity firm
we're going to put a team of lawyers on
this and he teamed up with windham
and he teamed up with blue green and he
teamed
diamond did and um
marriott and whoever else they could get
westgate whoever else they could get on
the list
and they decided to go after these
lawyers and different companies that
were running people out of timeshares
and they got they've got they've gotten
bad stories written about people
including they're going after me now
they've gotten
uh the attorney general in the state of
washington to
uh to try to prove that there was
something false going on and there
wasn't
and timeshare exit team although hugely
successful
over the years uh
has legal fees in the millions and
millions of dollars now trying to defend
themselves against this company
and they've run out of money they're
running out of money and so they had to
pull off of our show they couldn't
afford to advertise anymore
they run them out of business they're
running them out of business they're not
out of business yet
but they're having to defend themselves
against the uh attorney general state of
washington they're having to defend
themselves against a massive set of
lawsuits brought
time and time and time and time again
and all they have done is get people out
of time shares that's all they've done
and so that's why you don't hear them on
the air here anymore
and then inside edition shows up and
ambushes me for an interview
and wants to know why i'm why i endorse
timeshare exit team
lisa guerrera and charlie well lisa
guerrero and charlie even though i
didn't grant you an interview
in your ambush in the lobby of the omni
at the dallas that was so low class you
too
you ought to know better than that you
don't think i'm gonna come back and put
22 million people on notice how scummy
you are at inside edition
that was so low class so i'll answer
your question why did i endorse
timeshare exit team
because they were doing the right thing
and getting people out of timeshares
after companies like mikey's had screwed
them
that's why i endorsed that company and i
did it with great pride
and they got over 20 000 people out of
their timeshares
before the legal fees and the bogus
stuff from
bogus government officials i wonder how
much he was paid
wow how much were you paid lisa
how much was inside edition paid by the
time share companies
how much did they pay you i didn't know
you could buy a story on inside edition
i didn't i didn't think you all were
that i knew you were tabloid but i
didn't know you were that low
or are you just so dumb that you didn't
understand you were on the wrong side of
this argument on the basis of the
consumer
so this is why timeshare is not on the
air anymore timeshare exit team
but guess who's still on the air me
me and i'm sitting
in a 300 million dollar paid for
building
neck deep in cash you jerks
bring it bring it mikey
bring it you have done poke the wrong
bear you done pissed off the wrong
hillbilly
you have messed with me enough that i am
coming after you bozos
and i'm gonna make a hobby out of you
guys and you don't understand how
hillbillies work
we fight generationally ask the
hatfields and mccoys they don't even
remember why they're fighting and
they're still fighting
so diamond resorts hilton you made a
huge mistake
investing in diamond because i'm about
to destroy your freaking investment if i
have anything to do with it at all
i'm going to tell millions tens of
millions of people
over and over and over and over again
how bad mike flashkey is as a ceo
how scummy he is and how these companies
absolutely are screwing the consumer
over and over and over and over and over
again if any of you dave ramsey
listeners go into a diamond
presentation after hearing this i gotta
call you stupid
if any of you dave ramsey listeners go
into a westgate presentation after
hearing this
and you walk into the tiber tigers cage
in order to get a free pass to the zoo
and pet the tiger
hoping the tiger won't eat you you're
stupid i'm getting a free
a free hotel buy your own hotel
buy your own hotel do you hear the guy
calling in the first segment
22 000 he invested and used
the thing six times that's a nice hotel
where are you staying my god the four
seasons in paris france
i mean you can rent out the dead gum
come on people think think
don't be stupid rednecks and fall for
these people
don't be stupid these companies are
straight up evil
they are sucking the lifeblood out of
america's families
and we have got to stop them from doing
it and the only way to stop them is not
legally
they got too much power because they're
buying off lawyers they're running
lawyer you're that guy they're running
lawyers out of business unbelievable
the guy's having to shut down his legal
practice because he's overwhelmed with
law with court costs and legal fees to
protect himself
because he was acting as an attorney
to get people out how do you i mean 15
cases that guy's got right now
and that's just one guy you know how
hard it was for us to find him
we found him in 24 hours lisa it wasn't
hard to do a little investigative
reporting
and actually find out what's really
going on in this industry
if you were a real reporter
oh my gosh this is not hard you guys
this is not hard when something feels
slimy you know why
cause it's slimy
so diamond westgate windham
marriott bluegreen who am i leaving out
here
i won't leave anybody out just let you
guys know
you've been hassling my butt for two
years
behind the scenes and we just made it
public
game on boys game on
this is the ramsay show we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you